THE NERD IS STRONG IN THIS ONE.
[ ELECTRONIC BEEPING, CHIRPING ]
Narrator: THIS IS DONALD PAPP
AND HIS WIFE, SUSANNE...
SHOWING OFF THEIR SCI-FI WAY
OF COMMUNICATING.
IT SEEMS LIKE DONALD AND SUSANNE
HAVE LEARNED TO SPEAK DROID.
BUT THERE'S ACTUALLY SOME CLEVER
ENGINEERING GOING ONE.
Narrator: WHAT'S THE SECRET
BEHIND THIS CONVERSATION?
Wrigglesworth:
IN ORDER TO SPEAK DROID,
DONALD AND SUSANNE FIRST OF ALL
SPEAK NORMALLY INTO A HELMET.
AND INSIDE THE HELMET,
THERE IS A MICROPHONE,
BUT UNLIKE A REGULAR MICROPHONE,
WHICH PICKS UP SOUND WAVES
AS THEY TRAVEL THROUGH THE AIR,
A LARYNGOPHONE WHICH IS
PRESSED AGAINST THEIR NECK
PICKS UP THE VIBRATIONS
DIRECTLY AS IT COMES OUT
OF THEIR VOICE BOX.
THIS IS PERFECT
FOR THESE DROID HELMETS
BECAUSE THE MICROPHONES
ARE SO SENSITIVE,
THEY CAN SPEAK QUIETLY AND NOT
BE HEARD OUTSIDE THE HELMET.
[ ELECTRONIC CHIRPING ]
WHEN DONALD SPEAKS
INTO HIS HELMET,
HIS VOICE IS PICKED UP
BY HIS LARYNGOPHONE,
CONVERTED INTO
AN ELECTRICAL SIGNAL...
AND TRANSMITS IT WIRELESSLY
TO EARPHONES IN SUSANNE'S MASK.
AT THE SAME TIME
THAT DONALD'S VOICE
IS BEING TRANSMITTED TO SUSANNE,
ANOTHER ELECTRONIC SYSTEM
HAS DETECTED THAT HE'S SPEAKING
AND EMITS DROID SPEECH,
RANDOM BEEPS AND BOOPS FROM THE
CONCEALED SPEAKERS ON THE MASK.
THE OTHER GREAT THING
ABOUT USING A LARYNGOPHONE
IS THAT IT DOESN'T PICK UP
ANY OUTSIDE OR BACKGROUND NOISE.
THIS MEANS THAT THE ACTUAL DROID
NOISE THAT THE MASK IS MAKING
ISN'T TRANSMITTED
TO THE OTHER PERSON'S EAR.
[ ELECTRONIC BEEPING, CHIRPING ]
Narrator: YES, COMMUNICATION
IS KEY FOR EVERY MARRIAGE.
WELL DONE, GUYS,
FOR TAKING IT TO THE EXTREME.